Cu toții avem nevoie de capacitatea de a comunica informații private fără teama că cineva ne ascultă. Dar proiectarea unui
sistem infailibil pentru asta nu e ușoară. În episodul de astăzi din Qiskit in the Classroom, vom vorbi despre cum
ceva numit distribuție cuantică de chei poate
ajuta. Bun venit înapoi la Qiskit in the Classroom. În această serie, vom acoperi subiecte pe care le-ai putea întâlni într-un curs universitar
legat de calculul cuantic. Fiecare video vine cu un modul interactiv în descriere, așa că
asigură-te că îl verifici. Astăzi, vom pătrunde în tărâmul criptografiei cuantice. Criptografia este studiul
tehnicilor de comunicare securizată. Acest lucru este incredibil de important pentru multe aspecte ale vieților noastre. De fiecare dată când folosești o
parolă pentru a te autentifica pe un site, trimiți o plată digitală sau când guvernele transmit informații militare, totul se face
printr-un protocol criptografic, astfel încât un ascultător să nu poată afla secretele noastre. Dar există o tensiune aici. Cum
ne asigurăm că persoana cu care vrem să comunicăm poate înțelege mesajul nostru, dar nimeni altcineva nu poate?
De-a lungul istoriei, criptografii au venit cu o mulțime de protocoale diferite pentru a încerca să facă mesajele lor cât mai imune
față de ascultători posibili. Uneori, cele două părți care vor să comunice securizat convin asupra unui
cod dinainte, care sperăm că este atât de complicat încât un ascultător nu ar putea să-l spargă. Dar, după cum
oameni precum Alan Turing și alți spărgători de coduri din timp de război ne-au arătat, chiar și cele mai complicate coduri pot fi
sparte. În mod ideal, am dori să trimitem mesaje criptate în așa fel încât să nu existe absolut niciun tipar
și nicio modalitate prin care un ascultător să poată înțelege fără a deține și o cheie aleatorie secretă pe care doar expeditorul și
receptorul o știu. Dar astfel ne expunem unei noi vulnerabilități. Cum putem trimite această cheie și să fim siguri că
nimeni nu o interceptează? În 1984, Charles Bennett și Gilles Brassard au venit cu o
metodă pentru a trimite securizat o cheie cu biți cuantici, care se numește acum BB84. Caracteristica principală a acestor
biți cuantici sau qubiți care permite acest protocol este că ei respectă principiul incertitudinii. Nu poți măsura
un sistem cuantic fără a-l perturba. Astăzi, vom începe cu un exemplu de cod criptografic simplu. Apoi îți voi
arăta cum distribuția cuantică de chei și principiul incertitudinii ne pot permite să folosim criptări aproape de nedescifrат
Îți voi prezenta protocolul BB84 în detaliu și, în final, îl vom rula pe un calculator cuantic real.
Mai întâi, să începem cu un joc pe care poate l-ai mai văzut, numit criptogramă.
Ți se oferă o secvență de litere aparent aleatorie, dar folosindu-ți cunoștințele despre tipare din limba engleză
poți înlocui o literă cu alta pentru a înțelege mesajul. Iată un exemplu. Acesta este un
mesaj secret cu un cifru simplu de substituție. Deci, toate R-urile reprezintă o literă, M-urile reprezintă
o alta, și tot așa. Dacă vrei să încerci să-l rezolvi singur, pune videoul pe pauză acum.
Se dovedește că acest mesaj a fost criptat folosind un cifru foarte simplu numit cifrul Caesar, unde
alfabetul este pur și simplu deplasat cu un anumit număr, în cazul acesta 9. Deci A devine J, B
devine K, C devine L și tot așa. Cu cât mesajul este mai lung, cu atât este mai ușor de
văzut tiparul. Deci, cu un mesaj la fel de lung ca cel dat, cifrul Caesar sau orice alt cifru care doar
înlocuiește o literă din alfabet cu alta este destul de ușor de spart. O modalitate mai sigură de a codifica un mesaj secret
este cu așa-numitul bloc unic de cifrare. Cu un bloc unic, poți avea o deplasare diferită pentru fiecare literă din
mesaj. Trebuie doar să îi spui prietenului tău care a fost deplasarea pentru fiecare, ca să poată descifra mesajul.
Această listă de deplasări se numește cheia sau blocul. Se numește bloc unic pentru că este folosit o singură dată, apoi aruncat.
Dacă este folosit mai mult de atât, vor apărea tipare care ar putea face criptarea descifraбилă. Cu criptarea prin bloc unic,
atât mesajul criptat cât și cheia sunt individual doar un șir aleatoriu de nonsens. Dar
când le pui împreună, vezi un mesaj secret care emerge din zgomot.
Să facem un scurt exemplu. Să zicem că am creat deja și am trimis prietenului meu acest bloc unic care este de obicei scris în
binar. Și apoi vreau să trimit mesajul „I love quantum". Atunci aș codifica mesajul
folosind blocul unic astfel. Mai întâi convertim literele din mesajul nostru în binar. Fiecare literă de la A la Z va
corespunde numerelor de la 1 la 26 scrise în binar. Deci A va fi 0 0
0 1 B 0 0 1
0 C 0 0 1 1 și tot
așa. Iar un spațiu va fi doar toți de zero.
Atunci acesta este ce devine mesajul. Codificăm mesajul efectuând un XOR între fiecare bit din mesaj și
bitul corespunzător din blocul unic. Dacă nu ai mai văzut XOR înainte,
înseamnă SAU exclusiv. XOR-ul dintre doi biți va fi unu dacă doar unul
dintre biți este unu și zero dacă sunt fie amândoi zero fie amândoi unu. Deci primul set de cinci biți din mesajul codificat
devine 1 0
0 1 1. Îți las restul XOR-urilor să le faci singur. Dar ideea este că
acest mesaj este acum doar un șir aleatoriu de zerouri și unu fără niciun tipar. Este complet indescifrabil de oricine care
nu are blocul unic pe care l-am folosit pentru a cripta mesajul. Deci, ce am învățat până acum? Unele scheme de criptare
sunt mai bune decât altele, iar unele pot fi deduse de o persoană inteligentă care caută tipare în mesajul criptat.
Dar o cheie cu adevărat aleatorie care deplasează fiecare literă dintr-un mesaj secret cu o cantitate aleatorie diferită nu poate fi
dedusă deoarece nu există tipare în mesaj. Singura vulnerabilitate într-o schemă ca aceasta este să ne asigurăm că
cheia folosită pentru a cripta mesajul nu ajunge în mâini greșite. Iată unde intervine distribuția cuantică de chei.
Prin utilizarea qubiților, Bennett și Brassard au găsit o modalitate pentru două parties să convină asupra unei chei și
să fie rezonabil sigure că o terță parte nu asculta în secret. Protocolul BB84 este un pic complicat, dar
îl vom parcurge pas cu pas. Pentru această explicație, să readucem vechii noștri prieteni, Alice și
WEBVTT
Bob. Protocolul începe cu Alice care pregătește un set de qubiți pentru a-i trimite lui Bob. Acești qubiți conțin
informațiile care vor deveni blocul lor unic partajat sau cheia. Alice generează mai întâi două secvențe aleatoare de
aceeași lungime. Una este o secvență aleatoare de zerouri și unu, iar cealaltă este o secvență aleatoare de x-uri și z-uri reprezentând
baza în care ea își va pregăti qubiții. Apoi ea va pregăti fiecare qubit într-o stare cuantică conform
combinației de bază și valoare de bit prezentate în acest tabel. Deci dacă bitul este zero și baza este z, ea va
pregăti qubitul în starea zero. Sau dacă bitul este unu și baza este X, îl va pregăti în starea minus. Dacă
nu ești sigur ce sunt aceste baze și stări cuantice, e în regulă. Principalul lucru pe care trebuie să-l știi este că
măsurătorile în fiecare bază au doar două rezultate posibile. 0 sau unu pentru baza Z și plus sau minus pentru baza X.
Dacă măsori starea zero în baza Z, vei obține întotdeauna zero.
Dar dacă măsori acea aceeași stare în baza x, vei obține un rezultat aleatoriu, fie plus fie minus, fiecare cu o probabilitate de 50%.
Deci Alice ar putea pregăti un șir de qubiți astfel, unde acesta este șirul aleatoriu de
zerouri și unu, iar acesta este șirul aleatoriu de x-uri și z-uri. Deci primul element din fiecare dintre
cele două secvențe ale ei a fost 0 și x. Deci asta înseamnă că ea va pregăti primul qubit în starea plus și tot
așa. Odată ce a pregătit toate stările qubiților, Alice îi va trimite lui Bob acești qubiți, iar Bob va alege aleatoriu între X
și Z ca bază în care să măsoare fiecare unul. Deci acum adăugăm câteva rânduri la
tabel pentru a reprezenta alegerile și măsurătorile lui Bob. Deci iată alegerile lui Bob
de măsurători și baze. Și iată rezultatele sale de măsurare ale qubiților pe care i-a trimis Alice. În final, Bob
poate converti fiecare măsurătoare într-un bit folosind același tabel pe care Alice l-a folosit pentru a-și pregăti qubiții. Când măsoară
starea zero sau plus, atribuie valoarea de bit zero. Iar unde măsoară starea unu sau minus, pune un
unu. Deci șirul final de biți al lui Bob este acest rând final.
Observă că atunci când bazele din pasul de pregătire al lui Alice și pasul de măsurare al lui Bob se potrivesc, atunci biții lor se vor potrivi și ei,
de asemenea. Dar dacă Alice alege să pregătească Z și Bob măsoară în X sau invers,
atunci biții corespunzători ai lui Alice și Bob nu vor fi neapărat la fel. Deci, o modalitate prin care amândoi pot conveni asupra unui șir de biți
pentru blocul lor unic este să se sune și să-și spună reciproc ce baze au folosit pentru fiecare qubit.
Când bazele se potrivesc, păstrează bitul, iar când nu se potrivesc, îl aruncă.
Deci, în acest caz, Alice și Bob vor conveni amândoi asupra unui șir de biți de 0 0 1 0
0. Cum protejează această schemă împotriva ascultătorilor nedetectați? Ei bine, să vedem ce se întâmplă când un astfel de ascultător
pe nume Eve interceptează qubiții pe care Alice îi trimite lui Bob. Ea nu știe în ce stare se află acești qubiți sau cum
i-a pregătit Alice. Deci, datorită principiului incertitudinii și a ceva numit teorema non-clonării, ea nu poate
pur și simplu să facă o copie identică a qubiților pentru a o transmite lui Bob. Dacă ar putea, atunci ar putea
asculta fără a fi detectată. În schimb, ea ghicește o bază în care să măsoare fiecare qubit, îi măsoară și apoi
pregătește un nou set de qubiți falsificați pentru a-i trimite lui Bob. Există și alte modalități mai viclene prin care Eve ar putea încerca să
afle despre qubiți, dar niciuna nu ocolește principiul incertitudinii.
Deci, vom presupune pur și simplu această metodă directă de interceptare a lui Eve. Iată un tabel care descrie
pregătirea lui Alice, interceptarea lui Eve și măsurarea finală a lui Bob. Deci acum, când
Alice și Bob vorbesc la telefon pentru a-și compara bazele, vor decide să păstreze acești biți pentru cheia lor, dar
biții nu se potrivesc. Acest lucru se datorează faptului că Bob măsura qubiți pe care Eve i-a pregătit, nu qubiții originali pe care îi avusese Alice.
Dacă compară un subset din biții șirurilor lor de biți unii cu alții, vor vedea că unii nu se potrivesc și
vor presupune că trebuie să fi existat un ascultător. Deci, deoarece Eve a fost descoperită, Alice și Bob vor arunca
șirurile lor de biți și vor reîncepe protocolul de la zero. Dar dacă Eve nu ar fi ascultat și subsetul de
biți pe care Alice și Bob i-au comparat s-ar fi potrivit, atunci ar putea merge mai departe și folosi biții rămași pe care nu i-au
comparat ca cheie partajată. Odată ce Alice și Bob au o cheie partajată, atunci Alice poate trimite mesaje criptate lui Bob, iar
Bob este singurul care le poate decripta folosind cheia. Acum că am parcurs protocolul, haideți să-l încercăm pe un
calculator cuantic. Există câteva lucruri de ținut minte pentru acest experiment. În primul rând,
BB84 este cu adevărat util doar dacă Alice și Bob sunt departe unul de celălalt. Pentru experimentul pe care suntem pe cale să-l facem, Alice
și Bob se află pe același chip cuantic. Deci, acest experiment nu va fi util pentru schimbul de informații private, dar este
totuși o demonstrație conceptuală bună a BB84.
În al doilea rând, calculatoarele cuantice reale au zgomot. Deci chiar dacă baza de pregătire a lui Alice se potrivește cu baza de măsurare a lui Bob
și nu a existat niciun ascultător, există totuși o șansă mică să măsoare biți diferiți din cauza erorilor din
calculatorul cuantic. Când compară șirurile lor de biți pentru a verifica ascultătorii, trebuie să aibă o anumită toleranță la erori înainte de a
concluziona că un ascultător trebuie să fi interferat cu ei și să arunce toată cheia. Acum, cu aceste
avertismente, să începem cu un experiment fără ascultători. Mai întâi, generăm aleatoriu
trei șiruri de biți diferite, fiecare cu 20 de biți. Primul este șirul inițial de biți al lui Alice.
Al doilea este o listă de baze în care Alice îți va pregăti qubiții.
Aici am ales zero pentru a reprezenta baza Z și unu pentru a reprezenta baza X. Lista finală este bazele în
care Bob va măsura fiecare qubit. Pe baza acelor trei liste, putem face un circuit diagram cu instrucțiuni pentru
pregătirea lui Alice și măsurătorile lui Bob. Toți qubiții încep în starea zero. Deci pentru a-și pregăti qubiții în
baza Z, Alice fie nu face nimic pentru starea zero, fie aplică un gate NOT sau X, afișat ca cutiile albastre etichetate X,
pentru starea unu. Pentru a pregăti în baza X, ea aplică fie un Hadamard gate care duce zero în starea plus
fie un gate NOT urmat de un Hadamard pentru a pregăti starea minus. Apoi ea trimite qubiții lui Bob. Setul următor de cutii
din circuit reprezintă măsurătorile lui Bob. Pentru a măsura în baza Z, el nu trebuie să aplice niciun gate suplimentar.
WEBVTT
El măsoară pur și simplu, ceea ce este reprezentat de aceste cutii gri. Pentru a măsura în baza X, el aplică mai întâi un Hadamard și
apoi măsoară. Vom rula acest circuit folosind Qiskit runtime primitive sampler. Iar rezultatul este șirul de biți al lui Bob
din măsurători. Apoi putem compara șirurile de biți ale lui Bob cu șirul inițial de biți al lui Alice, aruncând biții
unde bazele lor nu s-au potrivit. Și vedem că amândoi obțin aceeași cheie.
Reține că acesta este hardware real, deci ocazional s-ar putea să existe un bit care ar trebui să se potrivească dar nu se potrivește. În acest caz, toți
biții se potrivesc, dar dacă rulezi din nou pe cont propriu, ai putea obține o eroare, dar atâta timp cât fidelitatea este aproape de unu,
Alice și Bob pot fi rezonabil siguri că nu a existat niciun ascultător. Acum să vedem ce se întâmplă dacă Eve interceptează
qubiții. Acum avem două circuite. Primul arată pregătirea lui Alice și interceptarea și
măsurarea lui Eve. Următorul arată pregătirea de qubiți falsificați a lui Eve și măsurarea lui Bob. Putem
rula aceste circuite ca înainte, apoi să vedem ce ar obține Alice și Bob când compară șirurile lor de biți.
De data aceasta obțin o fidelitate de 6 repetat. Aceasta este mult mai mică decât
ce poate fi explicat prin zgomotul calculatorului cuantic. Deci concluzionează că Eve asculta. Calculul cuantic este
bine cunoscut și adesea exagerat pentru potențialul său de a rezolva probleme dificile. Dar comunicarea cuantică și criptografia
primesc adesea mult mai puțină atenție, deși potențialul pe care îl poate oferi cuantica în aceste domenii este la fel de
semnificativ și interesant. Astăzi am discutat cel mai timpuriu protocol descoperit pentru distribuția cuantică de chei, care este
practic imun la interceptarea nedetectată. Dacă vrei să încerci să trimiți un cod de nedescifrаt cu
o cheie certificată cuantic, mergi la modulul din descriere.
Mulțumesc că ai urmărit și ne vedem data viitoare.